اكثر من 50 مليون قناه على يوتيوب حول
العالم في وقت يتسابق كثير من المدونين
الاستعراض اكبر قدر من تفاصيل حياتها وذلك
لتحقيق اعلى عدد من المشاهدات هناك ايضا
قناه ام وليد على اليوتيوب الطباخ
الجزائريه التي لم يظهر وجهها ابدا على
مدار سبع سنوات ام وليد او مطبخ ام وليد
الذي يتابع قناتها اكثر من احد عشر مليون
مشترك اثاره الجدل مؤخرا بعدما كشف الموقع
الامريكي نتورك عن ارباح القياسيه تحققها
قناتها الموقع شارع ان الثروه وليد من
يوتيوب قد تصل الى اربعه ملايين دولار
واكثر وربما تحقق ما يزيد على
55,000$ شهريا لكن ام وليد خرجت عن صوتها
كشفت ان ما ورد عن ثروتها غير دقيق وانما
تتقاضى مبالغ صغيره حسب عدد المشاهدات
والمشتركين مقاطع وليد حققت نحو مليارين
ونصف المليار مشاهده منذ اطلاق القناه
وتعتبر اول امراه في المغرب العربي تحقق
هذا العدد من المشتركين والمشاهدات
[موسيقى]
ما هي المتطلبات حتى يصبح اي احد منا
يوتيوبر ويعني وكيف تتم الطريقه يعني
بدايه لازم يكون اسهل طريقه لعمل الفلوس
على اليوتيوب غير انه تبيعين منتج او
سبونسر شيب هي عن طريق اعلانات جوجل
شلون انت لازم يكون عندك
او سبسكرايب
4000 مشاهده على مدى عام بعدين شلون تسوين
ياخذ منك يجيب تسوين بارتنر شيب ويا
يوتيوب ويجيب لك الاعلانات مع الجوجل الان
كل 1,000 مشاهده للاعلان مو للفيديو اللي
يتابع لك كل 1000 مشاهده للاعلان تاخذين
عليها 18 دولار كل 1000 مشاهده للفيديو
تاخذين عليها ثلاثه الى خمس دولارات فهذه
طبعا بالاول
دولار يوتيوب
155 % الك هذه مبدئيا كيوتيوبر الى اي مدى
يصل دخل المؤثرين لنعرفهم تعرفيهم انت
ومشاهدين البارحه اتصلت بشركه 91 هي احدى
الشركات المسؤوله هنا عن تسويق او التعامل
مع الانفلونزا وربطهم بالماركات اليوم
الشركه خبرتني طبعا حسب كل شيء اعتمد على
الانفلونزاروين وهو من وين بالنسبه
للمنطقه جدا يعتمد عندي
السعوديه البوبيلار اكثر او المشهور اكثر
هو السناب شات فياخذ اللي عنده 100,000
ولا ياخذ 2,000 دولار فما فوق على البوست
الواحد الاستوري ارخص بينما اذا عندها
500,000 ولا يعني نص مليون فما فوق ياخذ
اربعه الاف دولار كلاس على البوست الواحد
بس على سناب همم هذا الحكي بالسعوديه
بالنسبه همم انستغرام بالنسبه للسناب شات
اغلى ياخذ تقريبا اذا عندك نص مليون اكثر
من 5000$ على
الامارات ههه
اكثر الانستغرام يلا شدي حيلك ما بقدر ال
100 الف دولار تقريبا
100,000 ولاور ياخذ 2000 دولار فما فوق
على البوست واربعه الاف دولار فما فوق على
البوست بينما السناب شات اقل في الكويت
اقل تقريبا 1000 اذا 1000$ على البوست
لانه يمكن البوبيليشن ابل في مصر مثلا
بوبيوليشن اعلى بس القوه الشرائيه اقل
الاشخاص فقال عندك احتماليه انه هذا الشخص
يسوي شوبينج اللي الحين على الانستغرام
تقريبا 44% من المستخدمين يسوون قرار شراء
على الاقل واحد على الانستغرام
فهذا بس هذا الكلام اقل في مصر لدى
الانفلونسر همم ياخذ فلوس اقل او يتشرج
اقل تقريبا 500$ الى 1000$ ايضا في الاردن
لبنان بعد المغرب بالعربيه الفيسبوك
واليوتيوب هي اللي يعني الفلوس
متابعين همم